c'était il ya quinze ans jour pour jour
le 16 février donc 2005 le protocole de
kyoto qui entrait en vigueur quelques
années après sa ratification
l'objectif de cet accord international
le site est de contraindre les pays
industrialisés à réduire leurs émissions
de gaz à effet de serre je retrouve à
berlin en direct ce matin stéphane
guillon ambassadeur du canada en
allemagne
ancien ministre fédéral de
l'environnement également le studio
bonjour qu'ils ont donc qui ont passé
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du protocole
de kyoto
vous aviez d'ailleurs présidé la
première coque
la première conférence des nations unies
sur le climat suivant l'entrée en
vigueur du protocole
quel regard vous portez aujourd'hui sur
l'état des choses
le protocole de kyoto était loin d'être
parfait mais c'était d'accord qu'on
avait il fallait le sauver
donc à la conférence que dont vous
parlez c'est qu'a eu lieu à montréal en
décembre 2005 il a fallu le mettre en
oeuvre
c'est à dire qu'on avait les nombres les
chiffres pour avoir suffisamment de pays
qui votent techniquement l'appuyer il y
avait beaucoup de pays qui voulait
renoncer dont les etats-unis qui étaient
sous la présidence du président de
groupe de gorilles ou bush qui voulait
renoncer surtout pas qu'on entreprenne
la négociation de la seconde phase du
protocole de kyoto
les gens se rappellent peut-être que le
protocole de kyoto avec une première
phase et se devait se terminer en 2012
et on devait prévoir une deuxième phase
à près de beyrouth et donc lors de cette
conférence de montréal
il a fallu rallier tout le monde et ça a
été très difficile c'était nécessaire
car c'est un enjeu mondial qui connaît
pas de frontières et même si nos accords
sont des êtres parfaits comme l'accord
de paris est pas parfait il faut se
battre pour les garder parce que sinon
on aurait pu relier way aujourd'hui en
2001 lundi que le canada s'engage à
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de 30% par rapport au niveau de
2005 donc l'année de la conférence dont
on vient de parler et à d'ici à 2030
donc et puis à d'être car bonheur ici
2050 est ce que vous y croyez
concrètement ce que c'est vraiment
possible tout ça vient beaucoup de
ils ont fait le même engagement l'europe
l'union européenne s'engage aussi à être
carbonique pour 2050
elle prévoit réduire ses émissions de
30% pour 2030 parce que pour se rendre à
zéro en 2050
vous devez réduire de beaucoup pour 2030
par rapport à 1990 qui était donc le
barème de kyoto donc on est plusieurs
dans cette situation là je reviens de
finlande puisque je suis aussi envoyé
spécial du premier ministre pour toute
l'europe et j'ai dû aller en finlande et
récemment à eux il veut aller carbonite
pour 2035 wii sera un cédant 15 ans
d'ici ça donc c'est très exigeant ça
suppose qu'on doit sortir beaucoup des
hydrocarbures actuellement voyez-vous
80% des sources d'énergie primaire de
l'humanité tourne autour du charbon du
gaz naturel et du pétrole pendant
pendant ce temps-là au canada qui
poursuit les grands projets de pétrole
des sables bitumineux dans l'ouest du
pays vous avez certainement entendu
parler du fameux chantiers gazier à
costa rica ce link qui crée est beaucoup
beaucoup de mécontentement par le
britannique situé en territoire
autochtone qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces projets-là en 1990 80 % source
d'énergie primaire nous l'humanité
c'était le pétrole le charbon et gaz
naturel au moment où ce sport est encore
80 pour ça malgré tous les efforts qu'on
a faits pour développer plus les
éoliennes le solaire l'électrification
donc on a un travail énorme vous parlez
du canada ont regardé la norvège
j'adorais choulet carbo 2 to hell ou si
elle est aussi de réduire ses émissions
de 55% pour 2030 parce que ni européenne
ne veut plus que ce soit seulement 30%
et vu que ce soit 55% norvège chypre
dans l'union européenne mais le même
objectif et vient d'annoncer ça mais il
ya encore récemment la norvège a annoncé
des projets de développement de ces
sources pétrolières se sont adonnés
fille pourra beaucoup beaucoup de pays
bien sûr mais si on regarde la situation
au canadien
on parle d'une transition énergétique
alors qu'on parle également d'une
urgence climatique
est ce que le gouvernement entre d'eau
devrait stopper tous ces projets là de
développement j'entends beaucoup de
gouvernements comme le dos qui font
preuve de beaucoup de courage en dix ans
la population ce que j'ai essayé de
faire ma même en 2008 ans était chef de
l'opposition
pour y arriver il faut mettre un prix ou
aux émissions de carbone tant qu'elles
sont gratuites considère notre
atmosphère comme une poubelle
eh bien on n'arrivera pas les réduire
suffisamment donc gouvernement canadien
comme vous le savez à ce projet qui fait
beaucoup qui enclenche beaucoup insisté
dans les provinces et ce l'est aussi en
europe je suis en allemagne en ce moment
ils ont des résistances dans certaines
l'indoor donc province allemande qui
dépendent beaucoup de charbon google
talk ou de résistance auprès des
populations et donc on doit avancer avec
tout le monde si quelqu'un arrive avec
un projet qui est peu réaliste qui met à
la porte clés de travailleurs dans des
communautés entières
ben ce quels que soient par élire et on
aura la place des maths aux sceptiques
qui feront rien du tout donc on doit
encourager je crois les politiciens les
plus déterminés et les plus pragmatiques
les plus réalistes en même temps pour
garder notre population avec nous à fait
de réduire nos émissions lenteur des
pays développés mais si vous êtes en
aide ou en inde aujourd'hui j'ai encore
des centaines de millions de gens qui
n'ont pas accès à l'électricité
et si on ne fait pas attention ça va
être le charbon qui vont leur donner
accès à l'électricité et ça ça va
augmenter nos émissions encore stéphane
dion merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté nous
parler en direct de berlin ce matin
merci bien je vous remercie beaucoup au
revoir